[music playing]
- It's snowing out, a little
snowing, white Christmas.
- I know it's going
to happen any day now.
- So the plan that they came
up with was rather ingenious.
They decided to take
Paul Castellano out
by luring him to one of
his favorite restaurants
with captains that he
absolutely trusted.
Their scheme was
all the shooters--
and they had many of
them because they wanted
to be able to pull this
off-- were going to be
in trench coats, Russian hats.
You see that a lot in New
York and it's just so nothing,
no one's really going to
pay attention to anything.
If anything, they'll
focus on, well
it was a guy with a trench
coat and a Russian hat,
I can't tell you
anything else about him.
One of the busiest sections
of midtown Manhattan,
4 o'clock in the afternoon,
around the holidays.
- So John Gotti who
was in the car up
the corner with Sammy the Bull.
He hated Paul so much
that he wanted to see
him laying in the street.
- I happened to be
with another guy.
I was at dinner at his house
sitting at the kitchen table,
and he had a little
television on the table.
And while I was
sitting eating, we get
some 911 texts on our beepers.
Back in those days
it was beepers.
And I kept getting
them, 911, 911.
And behind the 911,
I'm getting 98.
That means come to the club
on 98 Street, the Bergin.
So I know something happened.
It's all over the news.
It's flashed everywhere
that Paul Castellano was hit
in front of Sparks Steak House.
- Big Paul Castellano,
reputed godfather
of the Gambino
family, was on his way
to a Manhattan steak house.
As he stepped from
his black Lincoln,
three men wearing fur hats
and trench coats suddenly
appeared, pulled guns, pumped
six bullets into Castellano,
and six into his top
capo, Thomas Belotti,
and then calmly walked away.
- I was upstairs in my room, and
all of a sudden on the news I'm
hearing Paul
Castellano, mob boss,
is killed outside
Sparks Steak House.
And I'm thinking wow,
who could have done this?
- After the hit, Sammy Gravano
and John Gotti drove the car
down the street, and they slowed
up and looked at the bodies
and kept on going.
[police chatter]
- Because he was a gangster.
And he wanted to be there
and see it for his own eyes.
And then John was the boss.
- The old time mob
bosses, you see,
you know, they ruled
with an iron fist
covered with a velvet glove.
Well Gotti saw no
need for the glove,
that's what it came down to.
This was a hostile takeover
in every sense of the word.
- After he was killed
and John became the boss,
all the heroin dealers that
were around John all got
straightened out.
- Gotti was a boss who
reflected the times.
He was always grabbing and
reaching for more and more.
- So by the time we
reach about 1986, 1987,
we expand the heroin business
into the cocaine business.
I have Colombian connections.
So we're coming
in from Colombia,
there's loads coming in from
Miami, coming in from Detroit.
- The allure was money,
and very easy money.
If you've got the connections,
it's about the logistics.
It was money.
- So we go out to
the Hamptons, Fire
Island, party, drink, broads.
Champagne flowing from
the morning till night.
Listen, when you have keys to
the city like John Gotti did.
He was arrogant, he didn't
care that he broke every rule.
- You know this is supposed
to be, Cosa Nostra, our thing.
When John Gotti took over,
it was no longer our thing,
it was my thing.
- His transformation
was like a caterpillar
turning into a butterfly.
All the sudden he's
wearing $3,000 ties,
and the cocoon opens, and
out comes the Dapper Don.
- He's out and about.
He's good with a quip
and a sound bite.
- Why don't you just
behave yourself?
- I'm behaving myself.
- You're not behaving yourself.
- John Gotti changes the whole
dynamic of organized crime.
No longer the old Sicilian
style, make money not
headlines, stay in the shadows.
The idea was what's the
point of being a gangster
if nobody knows where you are?
- Every 4th of July, he
throws a free fireworks
bash for the neighborhood.
When police have
tried to stop it,
the crowds have
driven them back.
Gotti is somewhat of
a local hero here.
- Ironically, the neighborhood
thinks John Gotti is keeping
the drug dealers out of here.
Yet John Gotti is a drug dealer.
But he's not the guy peddling
it on the street, right?
So it's the perception, he's
saving us from drug dealers.
No he's not.
- Gotti was every day in
your face, look at me,
I'm a gangster doing this.
And that drives law enforcement.
[music playing]